oh sorry I was just resting here after
google's 3 our keynote three hours but I
was paying attention at least during
most of it here are the five biggest
things that Google announced number one
there's a new version of Android coming
to phones tablets and laptops Google
didn't give the name of the next version
it's just calling it the L version for
now but it's got a brand new material
design as Google's calling it it looks
really clean and has an array of new
features including new notifications on
the lock screen and a new browser number
two Android is coming to your body
Android wear is here and so are the
smart watches that run the new software
the software puts android smartphone
notifications google search recipes
reminders steps taken and lots of other
information on your wrist you'll also be
able to get third party apps for your
watch google showed off pinterest and a
recipe app android also wants to ride
shotgun android auto is coming to cars
google now and google maps are coming
right to your dashboard of course that
means other android apps riding in the
front seat too there are music apps like
pandora and others like MLB at bat 40
car makers including honda audi and ford
have signed up to sell cars with android
auto i know you've heard this before but
google's trying to take over your TV
again android TV android TV works a lot
like the other services it's going to
let you stream video from google play
and other services to your TV it also
has chromecast functionality which lets
you stream what you're watching on your
android phone right to the big screen
number 5 android is finally coming to
Chromebooks well google has kept its
operating system separate they're soon
going to allow Android apps to run on
Chrome OS laptops Google sundar Pichai
shut off an Android Evernote app on a
Chromebook as well as Flipboard you'll
be able to use your android phone to
also unlock your Chromebook so three
hours summarized in one sentence Google
wants Android to be everywhere
you